[Music]
are you looking for a gift for someone
special
or perhaps treating yourself well we got
you covered this video is sponsored by
pewdiepie store represent.com pewdiepie
the hottest
the freshest merch in the game now with
the classical
pewdiepie design shirts these are so hot
i haven't even gotten mine yet i love
these designs they're so cool and we
finally have
the classic pewdiepie wave merch design
we got a jacket we got a t-shirt and we
got a hoodie
and that's right christmas ornament
i know you want this but most
importantly show everyone how big your
brain is
with the big brain beanie brick baby so
check out represent.com
pewdiepie we have a ton of really cool
merch there it's really
cool i said it twice that's how cool it
is
100 mail club hottest merch in the game
let's get real here it's probably the
best way to support the channel and uh
yeah that's what you want to do i don't
know
back to the video cringe pewdiepie
submissions
i'm not cringe which means
i'm definitely cringe let's freaking do
this
the reddit cringe pewdiepie submissions
the worst
of the worst the six nine xds
the whole sound my friend who watched
pewdiepie died can i get
hey i've seen the bits of this before
but i thought it's time i'm ready let's
do this
this post with arguably the worst meme
form i've ever had
30 000 upvotes please kill me
damn it usually i brush the cringe off
me like you know what
they have no upvotes it doesn't matter
30 000 all right let's see it
oh really do you like anime oh i love
anime friendship hundred
i don't see what's cringe about this two
grown-ups liking anime
[ __ ] does that mean i'm cringe god damn
it why do they have to drag ksi into
this
i know i [ __ ] hate pewdiepie fans for
trying to corrupt
jj with their unfunny jokes
okay because him and felix did a very
recently with each other reacting to
reddit yet again no we didn't
like it's not a totally unoriginal
boring choice to make videos on or
anything
guys we have actual hate what the [ __ ]
says when did pewdiepie get a mustache
and why he got it for no not november i
think
that's stupidest [ __ ] what
oh no oh no you guys are cringe
oh that's so [ __ ] stupid
uh no i got it for prostate cancer but
you feel really
stupid now huh i know trust me guys i
get it there's a lot of really
really cringy posts and some honestly
genuinely pissed me off as well
all right this isn't a meme this is real
dad why is the fbi here
minecraft 2 minecraft 2 the fbi is here
and they're saying minecraft 2.
what does that mean i mean this is
beauty this is a great obscure meme you
guys just don't get it
i mean okay this is obviously a child
this is the problem when you have
a bigger subreddit there's a lot of [ __ ]
trust me
you sort by new and the pewdiepie
submissions you're a brave soul and i
respect you
girls on snapchat boys on snapchat
honestly i don't use snapchat so i can't
tell you if this is accurate or not
but girls don't use the funny filters
girls only care about pretty
yeah oh you like pewdiepie name every
subreddit you ruined
from okay buddy [ __ ] okay
okay buddy [ __ ] uh
every summer date i reviewed we won mr
stark
reddit 4.9 tick tock 4.8
we did it mrs stark we did it we did an
avengers meme template in 2020
keep them coming hell yeah hell yeah
this isn't really cringe this is just
really bad memes i would say
right is anyone actually cringing at
this i want to [ __ ] see the lives of
the people who post this damn bro calm
down
okay it's probably just a kid
when i was a child i was just a chad i
never done
anything cringy in my life damn there's
a lot of actual hate in these
i didn't expect that it's kind of weird
uh very epic indeed
time traveler what are you watching me
pewdiepie time traveler
president shelberg or his son felix
ginger
[Music]
see again we don't know how many up
boats this is okay
clearly not the best meme is it cringed
though
i don't think so like i want the cringe
trust me
i'm here for it imagine being the
children of felix
this is what people fantasize about okay
you'll have so much pressure on you
not for me people want you to be funny
or relevant just like your dad you will
be bullied at school
but siri
the comments are more cringe but
seriously though i already feel bad for
philly's kid because of pewdiepie's
community
yeah i like pewter and his content but
his fans are the worst pewdiepie's fans
on this sub
none pewdiepie fans on this sub hating
the pewdiepie subreddit
okay i'm glad there's a middle ground at
least
i appreciate that yeah beyond cringe tr
yeah
you gotta go beyond the cringe you just
gotta ride that way man
hey guys sven from pewdiepie's minecraft
series here to explain the joke
so basically our cringe pewdiepie
submission has
okay that's kind of funny over nine
thousand and one subscribers which is
over nine thousand i reference to the
meme with goku okay
yeah yeah yeah good [ __ ]
i missed my cake day we've all been
there bro
it's okay nobody cares oh we got a live
discussion happening all right
what the [ __ ] is happening why is this
come
nice uh will you press the button
fortnite gets deleted
or tick tock gets deleted
for not bad tick tock bad saying that
bad things are bad is bad
that's my level ready assemble
a lot how they still use reddit but they
clearly hate reddit
yeah i hate these posts like i get it
you want to pay tribute but it just it
doesn't fit a meme format it just
doesn't
yeah this is probably the most
legitimate it's not cringe but if
there's one thing to criticize for
is when people repost stuff especially
art
and then it gets more upvotes that's
fair that's fair
floor gang boo better get better
material
big peepee big brain it's sticker
i love instagram what the [ __ ] that's
where i get all my memes from
more than reddit trickster hundred me i
am a simp
me just kidding i am not psych i am haha
you're bamboozled i am not a sim what
the [ __ ]
is is this even supposed to mean did
they do a pewdiepie reference
in pewdiepie cringe reddit what the [ __ ]
is that even supposed to mean
yeah he destroys fifteen thousand dollar
lego sculpture an
hour after new exhibit opens every
redditor
every redditer
every single one of them ctrl c control
b maybe it's
getting the pewdiepie subreddit for the
first time
oh yeah when i miss i remember this this
is so annoying
because i thought aang was dragon ball
and every [ __ ] on the planet
pointed it out to me
yeah some stuff can be a bit redundant
hold up i'm curious how dangerous is it
to go to it
browse by new let's see it okay repost
nice okay that's not that bad
[Music]
that's literally from a video i posted
like 10 minutes ago
yeah this meme
is so old dude hey an original art
sam strain him with a right to the tip
of them what
and the court was screaming profanity
outrage
what is the reference of this i have no
idea but i like the art
it's nice oh it was when i did the
storytime yes
sorry
that's actually funny i like that hey
new and not so bad hey
what the [ __ ] everything i thought was a
was true is a lie
i guess this is this is the thing right
because uh
if there's ever a meme that i don't
particularly like or if uh
it's not funny i just scroll past it
it's not that because people for a while
were like
so i why the video not ending why my
meme not video
because it wasn't good okay i'm sorry
we care only about the top notch on
pewdiepie submissions all right
my crush i use reddit me prove it what
is 69
crush nice what do you think of fortnite
crush
i play minecraft she is a redditor
this feels more like a critique on
reddit culture in general than
pewdiepie submissions he writes a
mission mod when someone has an opinion
pewdiepie submission mod when
users threaten to kill a seven-year-old
because he likes fortnite and tick-tock
when did that happen
i'm pretty sure they would shut that
down i never seen anything like that
he really doesn't look like a legend he
looks like a weird dude adjusting his
glasses
trying to look cool with a robotic arm
but he's ultimately failing
i remember this so this kid got in
trouble in the internet
because he didn't like keanu reeves
right
it had nothing to do with my son right
why are you throwing me in there
did anyone ever say that to kill himself
because you like fortnite yes when
many times where someone links related
to someone else i like this one
bro do you really expect for me to name
one certain moment what the
[ __ ] do you think i am megamind i just
know it happened
i don't [ __ ] know when exactly that's
the best
source reference i've seen in my life
yeah
yeah you guys are projecting come on
that had nothing to do with me
you buy fans after getting into an
argument and realizing that they can't
just say your ceiling gang cringe
oh what if they can huh i'm honestly a
bit disappointed like i wanted the
cringe
i wanted to be part of the laughs i want
to go haha it's so bad but
the comments are more grinch there's got
to be some cringe in here
what they just don't make sense it's
just
marcia i'm sick i can't go to school
how are you too sick to go to school but
not too sick to play video games
why what about this is funny i don't
know
probably relatable for children
it's my birthday today turn 19. i always
wanted but can't afford these bad boy
headphones
read it do your magic and get me these
please ready
do your thing it got deleted come on
what normal people see what we see
really that's all you see when you look
at me am i some multi-million
dollar furniture corporation is that all
i
am to you it looks like any same stuff
gets
up
oh man yeah this is i think instagram is
even worse
i commented on marcia's post
and i swear to god every single comment
let's see if i can find it but she
painted the kitchen i said you did so
good because i know she worked hard on
it
and it's just simp
simp simp simp great
sim king slim i keep simp
simp sim every single
comment is is so unfunny
like jesus christ dude hey look at that
maybe if everyone says a joke it becomes
funnier
oh man oh god did i do it instagram bad
oh no
goddamn
total simp move bro my friend don't know
that i posted this here can we surprise
her with getting her to levi she got
huge pp
might as well start posting naked girls
for karma
it's probably not an actual girlfriend
just some photo off the web
yeah and she probably just photoshopped
those g fuels in there
oh god she's got huge pee pee please
shut the [ __ ]
up i saw this
is that a potato
yes it is i think it was a a stone from
the beach that might have brought home
for some reason
i don't know why it means random
potatoes very quirky
okay shadow band i'm
i don't even know you could do that
pewdiepie subreddit it's just all the
kids that get bullied at school
i like they're almost like criticizing
pewdiepie submissions
for bullying other kids somebody's also
like they're all kids being bullied
uh okay i didn't expect so much
animisticity
anonymity whatever it's called i was
hoping for more cringe
i'm disappointed
oh no felix just donated to a girl
during those of september
oh god yeah yeah that's bad
okay that's like that's cringe this is
very sad
god i don't want to laugh at it because
obviously uh i didn't even know
he passed away puke said he watched tom
and jerry as a kid moment of silence for
this legend
yeah the karma or farming for whenever
someone dies is so
weird and uncomfortable pewte said he
watched him again
when did i say that even this is so sad
it reminds me of another post that was
on the pewdiepie
submission edgar's getting old 48
000 uploads yeah i know i don't
what the [ __ ] is i said it like three
times before
that it's weird that people keep
bringing up how my dogs are aging it's
like yeah i know
i know what do you want me to do this is
so sad
pewdiepie's dog is gonna die soon look
how old he is this is so sad
please upload but i get it it's just a
kid they don't know better
but i don't need to be keep reminding of
it it's so strange
so in a way i agree but also i don't
know man
all right another avengers all of reddit
when pewdiepie
mr beast keanu reeves and dodge team up
to destroy cringe instagram
tick tock and fortnite because that's
what heroes do
nice xd epic
to be fair yes there's a lot of bad post
and yes i also think a lot of it is
projecting the
general reddit culture like big chunks
tick-tock bad fortnite band i i don't
even see that much of that
or even before when that was a thing i
didn't see much of that except minecraft
good i guess yeah no that one definitely
wants that actually
it's such a big reddit it takes a lot of
[ __ ] for it but
i will say despite a lot of annoying
cringy
weird there's a lot of 99
i think are amazing there's so i get so
much fun out of this subreddit it's one
of the best things i've done with this
channel because
it actually brought me back with my
community and we can interact together
every week have a back and forth which
is so fun it's something i look forward
to every week
to go through you know it's an update of
what happened kinda
and it probably doesn't make a lot of
sense for people that don't watch
pewdiepie
but i think it's really cool and it's
it's not just the memes it's also
amazing fan art it gives me a chance to
find it amazing
edits all the cocomell and stuff we've
seen some incredible stuff from man
so despite its flaws you know it's not
flawless obviously
i'm super proud of it i really am and
honestly a lot of the really
it's stupid like that's more cringe to
me
like you're doing the same thing you're
pretending you're against right
at least that's what i see it's a good
thing to remind uh even you guys
that just let people enjoy what they
like you know if other people like
fortnite
didn't let them who cares if people like
pewdiepie submissions
who cares let them right i feel like
with cringe
regarding pewdiepie because i think
pewdiepie has always been a little
cringe
throughout the years i remember i i kept
doing the brofist
and that became such a popular thing and
then people started making fun of it and
i was like oh yeah it is kind of lame to
do brofist
a bit of stuff but now i'm just like who
[ __ ] cares people like it
it's an endearing thing so on that note
thanks for watching
bro fish guys that was a big question
looking for some high level gaming gear
check out face
okay but of what top scientists have
determined
that wearing base gear makes you a
better gamer with at least
two percent basis for everyone no matter
what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i am of course
you have before december 11 to place
your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history books so what are you waiting
for
buff up your wardrobe today and head
over to base.gigi
basil i'm 68 i swear
can i order